pop up
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en intermède de la finale du championnat
de france de rugby le toro de fuego de
supporter dacquois avaient mis déjà le
feu aux poudres
et pourtant ni les joueurs de dax ni
ceux de béziers à droite de l'écran
maillot légèrement plus clair que ceux
de leurs adversaires avaient besoin de
cela pour s'expliquer d'une manière
souvent explosives
le match peut se résumer en trois coups
de pied dans le ballon et une série
d'autres coups plus ou moins aux crocs
distribués sans parcimonie premier coup
de pied dans le ballon
trois points pour les dacquois
[Applaudissements]
après cela on s'explique que chacun avec
son tempérament et selon son poids
une tonne et demie de muscles dans une
mêlée il faut bien ça explose de temps
en temps
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien le moment de sonner la charge
dans des tribus
[Musique]
puisqu'on ne peut attraper le ballon
autant se dépenser un peu en distribuant
quelques coups au hasard
ils ne mouraient pas tous mais tous
étaient frappés
[Musique]
enfin un second coup de pied dans le
ballon rond quoi pour daisy les dacquois
se réveille il se rappelle tout à coup
que le bon rugby se joue à la main oui
mais que ne ferait on pas pour garder le
ballon sous le bras
tout de même il y a eu un grand moment
dans ce match ce moment le voilà ballon
pour béziers à cinq mètres de la ligne
de but de dax un admirable coup de pied
de l'âne au sein de ses coups de pied
comme on en donne à tous les 50 ans sur
un terrain de rugby
béziers mc 3 points de plus cet exploit
donne la victoire à béziers par six
autres
bruxelles à l'heure du championnat
d'europe des poids coq le belge cosmas
large parements blancs sur la culotte
réalise son rêve il rencontre le
champion d'europe de la catégorie le
britannique fred ighil roj
yako ce mince est tout de suite dans le
vif du sujet il fait déjà connaissance
avec le tapis
à
et pourquoi pas deux fois pendant son
adversaire seulement voilà frais des
guides rome ne s'est pas que pierre
kossmann se récupère très vite
et à droite à son tour qu'il ne faut pas
trop rapidement vendre la peau de l'ours
maintenant vous êtes à égalité messieurs
pour celui d'entre vous qui tombera la
prochaine fois ce sera sûrement la bonne
vieille est à terre ça y est
[Applaudissements]
non pas encore ces deux boxeurs sont
extraordinaires ils se rendent coup pour
coup
[Applaudissements]
s'il n'y avait pas de bombe le combat
était fini et l'on commence comme si
rien ne s'était passé
le résultat ne va plus tarder guidera il
s'effondre encore ils voudraient bien
continuer son manager est plus sage que
lui il jette l'épongé
le britannique n'est plus qu'une poupée
désarticulée
le combat est terminé il a fallu une
offrande à pierre cosmas pour devenir
champion d'europe
un rêve qu'il réalise à l'âge de 30 ans
[Musique]
c'est un peu le monde de l'avenir coffre
aux investigations des mordus de tous
âges
le 24e salon international de
l'aéronautique du bourget où trône le
bombardier américain b 58 qui reliait
new york à paris en 3h20 l'illberg
il y à 34 ans avait mis plus de trente
deux heures à côté des maquettes
d'appareils dont on parlera mirage iv et
super caravelle l'aéronautique française
fait étalage de son écurie de fusée ces
fusées toute modestes qu'elles sont
témoins en tout cas que la france est
entrée dans la course
[Musique]
il reste bien entendu que la curiosité
conduira infailliblement à la vedette du
salon
la capsule mercury dans laquelle alan
shepard réaliser l'exploit qu'il a promu
au rang de second cosmonautes du monde
a paris le palais de chaillot a abrité
le 3e congrès mondial de la prévention
des risques professionnels
mille quatre cent cinquante délégués
représentant 52 nations sont venus se
pencher sur des problèmes qui
intéressent le monde du travail
ce que pose la sécurité des travailleurs
dans l'exercice de leur métier
[Musique]
la conférence d'evian suit jour par jour
son chemin n'a lésé l'hôtel du parc
ouvre régulièrement aux délégations son
salon hier sans histoire mais si l'on en
est encore qu'au prologue il n'en est
pas moins vrai que le banal salon
d'evian abrite aujourd'hui un dialogue
ce dialogue l'annoncé du cessez-le-feu
unilatéral ne l'a pas interrompu en
dépit d'une certaine mauvaise humeur
par contre elle a déclenché en algérie
un climat qui peut sembler nouveau il
semble qu'il y ait plus de monde sur les
plages les pique niques dans la forêt de
sidi ferruch avait été quelque peu
délaissé on ya trouvé cette semaine
comme une atmosphère de kermesse
[Musique]
dira-t-on qu'il ya une détente
c'est sans doute difficile mais les
affiches qu'on commence à voir partout
clame à tous les échos et même sur les
volets de la pharmacie de ferhat abbas à
sétif qu'un autre climat peut naître et
que la volonté de paix de la france est
évidente d'autant que cette volonté se
traduit par d'autres gestes en une
semaine
laliberté a été rendu à 2500 prisonniers
le chiffre sera porté à six mille dans
moins d'un mois
cette mesure n'était elle pas la preuve
d'un esprit qui peut faire une paix
véritable veut recréer la confiance
c'est cette volonté de paix traduite par
ses gestes et d'autre que 80
journalistes de tous les horizons sont à
les contrôler et constaté l'opinion
mondiale qui a accueillies avec faveur
les décisions du gouvernement français
que aussi bien raisonner sur des faits
contrôlée corps ont vu en effet ces
journalistes c'est reporter ses yeux
dont le métier est de voir pour d'autres
ils auront vu dans des rues animées des
foules qui vont à leur affaire des
cinémas plein des cafés pezi il ne
s'agit pas de nier les atteintes à il y
en a toujours
mais les arbres ne peuvent toujours
cacher la forêt et rien ne peut plus
dissimuler que l'algérie prend un
nouveau visage
[Musique]
c'était paris sans doute mais c'était la
france aussi qui faisait dans le
printemps des champs elysées le plus
beau des accueils au roi baudouin et à
la reine fabiola de belgique
le général de gaulle était allé vais
recevoir à leur descente d'avion et dans
le bruit des acclamations ou paris
exprimé son amitié se retrouve l écho de
la visite qu'avait fait voici 51 ans
le roi albert et la reine elizabeth le
jeune couple royal renouvelle à l'elysée
la chaîne des temps et il l'a renouait
avec cette précieuse qualité qu'est la
grâce de la jeunesse si protocolaire
qu'elle fut cette visite était une
visite d'amis et l'histoire de france
est trop proche de l'histoire de
belgique pour que le louvre ne fut pas
invité lui aussi à accueillir le roi
baudouin et la reine qui pour ce soir la
porte et le diadème de la reine astrid
[Musique]
les visiteurs ceva dès le lendemain vers
un autre séjour royal fontainebleau qui
vit tourner aussi quelques-unes des plus
grandes pages de l'histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le public parisien étaient nombreux le
soir aux portes de l'opéra pour voir
passer le jeune souverain et la reine
fabiola dont le sourire et la simplicité
ont déjà fait sa conquête
[Musique]
resplendissante soirée où après la
présentation des artistes et du corps de
ballet le plus choisi des publics saluer
dans la loge centrale l'un des plus
sympathiques parmi les couples salaires
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain au château de versailles le
roi baudouin était seule la reine
atteinte d'une légère maladie n'avait pu
l'accompagner dans cette visite au plus
somptueux des règnes français ce soir
comme voici 201 le palace animèrent
vivaient autour de visages célèbres et
de nos glorieux et c'est dans ce cadre
impérissable que s'achevait la visite
des souverains belges
la france avait pu en si peu de jours
leur offrir trois palais prestigieux le
louvre fontainebleau versailles la
grandeur de son histoire avec la ferveur
de son amitié
avant son départ pour paris où il allait
rencontrer le général de gaulle le
président kennedy avait dit je vais en
france pour contribuer aux relations
étroites qui doivent permettre de
sauvegarder la cause de la liberté
et dès le premier moment on pouvait
penser que ces deux hommes qui
représentent chacun des intérêts
différents parfois mais un esprit commun
pouvait bâtir une oeuvre utile à la
peine tout de suite aussi on avait pu
sentir la chaleur de la rencontre la
population parisienne le long du
parcours ne ménageait pas ses
applaudissements à ce duo illustres qui
porte aujourd'hui avec le destin de deux
grandes nations
une part du sort du monde
et dès l'arrivée à l'elysée qu'une armée
de photographes a siégé sans d'ailleurs
marquée des résultats spectaculaires
après cette photo du perron devenu
classique mais à laquelle le sourire de
jacqueline kennedy apportait un éclat
nouveau les entretiens prévus entre les
deux hommes d'état
comment c'est ça la seule les deux
hommes allaient après l'éviction des
photographes aborder l'examen des
dossiers d'une époque périlleuse madame
jacqueline kennedy accompagnée de madame
de gaulle devait dans l'après midi aller
visiter l'école de puériculture fondé en
grâce à la croix rouge américaine devant
ses petits enfants français jacqueline
kennedy n'a t'elle pas penser qu'elles
appartenaient un peu à cette grande
famille nationale où la famille bouvier
la sienne a toujours de profondes
racines
à ce moment les deux présidents
remontait sous la pluie les
champs-elysées pour aller faire devant
la tombe de l'inconnue le geste de piété
traditionnel mais ce geste était dans la
circonstance plus large et plus vrai
n'est ce pas à versailles qu'est née
l'indépendance américaine
c'est au nom de l'amitié celle les ce
jour-là que le président kennedy a signé
le livre d'or et kennedy n'at-il pas dit
lui même
la france notre plus vieil ami
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]